[Musique]
concorde à new york qui a un nouvel
espoir avec la décision du juge fédéral
roger nicolas disparaît à l'âge de 57
ans mon show man qui fait 10 des
chansons pour elvis presley témoigne en
direct de marseille
le président de la république demain
dans la meuse un voyage consacré aux
problèmes agricoles
bonsoir concorde à new york
ok d'accord a dit le juge fédéral milton
polak aujourd'hui les autorités de
l'aéroport kennedy doivent donc autorisé
le supersonique franco anglais atterrir
à new york
conformément au règlement sur le bruit
le juge paul ac n'a d'ailleurs pas
lésiné sur les adjectifs retard de
dix-sept mois excessif et injustifié
une interdiction discriminatoire
arbitraire déraisonnables at-il dit
dès qu'elle a appris la nouvelle ce soir
la compagnie british airways a fait
savoir qu'elle était prête dès que
possible a organisé en coopération avec
air france six vols expérimentaux de
concorde vers new york
il reste que les autorités de l'aéroport
kennedy et les opposants supersonique
ont dix jours pour faire appel de la
décision du juge pollack
si c'était le cas la procédure
judiciaire pourrait aller jusqu'à la
cour suprême des etats unis
cependant la poursuite du procès
n'empêcherait pas forcément concorde
d'atterrir
car l'autorisation accordée aujourd'hui
pourrait être confirmé par le juge
pendant que serait instruite la
procédure d'appel le juge polak a donné
10 jours pour que les opposants au congo
depuis ce faire appel il est probable
que les opposants feront appel est le
premier problème que nous avons devant
nous est de savoir si l'appel sera
suspensif ce il suspendra la décision
qui était devenu aujourd'hui nous ne
serons fixés que lorsque précisément le
juge d'appel se prononce en messieurs
nice cette affaire de concorde a pris
une importance assez grande en france
non seulement ce plan commercial de son
clan politique et c'est un sujet très
passionnel en cas d'échec de concorde
est ce que le gouvernement français
envisagerait des mesures de représailles
ou de rétorsion je ne puis que vous
renvoyer aux paroles du président de la
république lui-même qui dans une
interview accordée à jean américain a
indiqué très clairement que il
envisageait des mesures de rétorsion
éventuels car nous ne pouvons pas
accepter une attitude discriminatoire
une étude injuste vis-à-vis du concorde
mais que bien sûr on ne prendrait que
des mesures appropriées qui ne pénalise
le port l'économie française depuis la
nuit dernière avec la mort d'elvis
presley le monde du show business est en
deuil
gros titres dans les journaux et
émissions de radio et de télévision
spéciale un peu partout dans le monde
nous allons y revenir aussi bien sûr
mais avant ce soir sur le carnet noir du
music hall il faut ajouter un nom celui
de roger nicolas il est mort ce matin à
l'âge de 57 ans à son domicile à paris
ils étaient fantaisistes comme on disait
au moment de la guerre c'est à dire
qu'il racontait des histoires un emploi
et un homme bien différent d'être
presley bien sûr il n'ya pratiquement
pas de comparaison pourtant je suis sûr
que dans le coeur des français roger
nicolas tient une place vraiment
privilégié lui qui a fait rire plus
d'une génération avec ses blagues son
fameux écoute écoute et par exemple
cette histoire de théâtre un homme qui a
le trac
un peu comme au sens fort
[Musique]
il ya l'option coulisses qu'à une intro
tient le trac qui va pas rentrer juste à
vous et à vous montrer mes rentrées et
on le bouge seul cadeau itunes la touffe
et elle en reprend fait et comment ses
collègues peut plus bouger une
hôtellerie france comme le gars qui peut
pas parler fait
et oui il faut sourire quand même aux
états unis des centaines et des
centaines d'américains en téléphoner à
la maison blanche pour demander au
président carter une journée de deuil
national à l'occasion de la mort d'elvis
presley est décédé hier soir donc à
l'hôpital de memphis dans le tennessee
aucune mort depuis celle de l'ancien
président kennedy n'a autant ému le
peuple américains disent certains
commentateurs jugement excessif
ce n'est pas certain même ceux qui
n'apprécient guère le rock'n'roll cette
musique de sauvage comme le disait il ya
20 ans reconnaissent aujourd'hui qu'elle
dise presley a marqué son époque
phénomène commercial phénomène musical
phénomène sociologique aussi pour les
jeunes
il était devenu une idole comme james
dean et marlon brando et aujourd'hui
pour ses millions de fans qui aller
applaudir le monstre sacré du show
business mondial c'est le temps des
larmes
évidemment le spectacle doit continuer
dit le proverbe un spectacle qui avait
commencé pour elvis presley par une
belle histoire histoire de sel
[Musique]
pétain et vice c'est l'histoire d'un
enfant pauvre
né en 1935 qui grandit dans le tennessee
où il apprend les negro spiritual dans
les églises qu'ils fréquentent avec
assiduité
c'est l'histoire d'un adolescent qui
voudrait devenir ingénieur mais qui sera
contraint de conduire des poids lourds
c'est aussi l'histoire d'un chanteur qui
fait une percée fulgurante avec un
premier disque enregistré pour sa mère à
ses frais dans un petit studio dès lors
comme ils l'expriment il va pouvoir
sortir sa famille du pétrin sa musique
son style tient à la fois de la country
music du folklore du sud et du rythm n
blues c'est le rock
les critiques se déchaînent contre la
vulgarité la violence de ce voyou qui
n'en est pas un qui ne boit pas qui ne
fume pas ne se drogue pas et qui voue à
sa mère une affection sans bornes
son nom est associé en tant que
phénomène social au flipper audio boxe
au boutte aux motos et aux surboum à
partir de 1960 sous le contrôle d'un
manager mystérieux et omniprésent ancien
vendeur de hot dogs
baptisé colonel parker il tourne une
trentaine de films assez médiocre dans
des décors exotiques l'échec
elvis le connaîtra dans sa vie conjugale
son mariage à 21 ans avec priscilla
beaulieu fille de son commandant en
allemagne tournera court après la
naissance d'une petite fille mais ce
grand professionnel solitaire continuera
à répandre dans tous les pays quelques
300 millions de disques un record absolu
depuis 72 en semi retraite dans son
palais à cologne le même fils il soigne
une obésité dont l'origine reste
inconnue
il ne se produit plus que rarement dans
les super show à las vegas ou à honolulu
dans la rue qui porte son nom le long de
sa propriété à memphis la foule de ses
admirateurs se pressent aujourd'hui
attendant de conduire l'idole vers sa
dernière demeure
un monument baroque où l'attend sa mère
morte comme lui à 40 degrés
oui
[Musique]
oui les vêtements
alors que human vous êtes avec nous en
ce moment en direct depuis marseille
vous avez eu l'occasion de travailler
avec le disent pas cela oui enfin
travailler avec nous mais j'ai travaillé
pour c'est à dire j'ai écrit pas mal de
chansons pour lui et comment ça s'est
passé mans ben c'est à dire c'était un
peu comme on expliqué c'était
l'artisanat c'était la petite
manufacture c'était le travail à la
chaîne et c'était aussi un concours
c'est à dire qu'elle en était à peu près
une dizaine ou une vingtaine je me
souviens plus qui travaillaient pour lui
presque exclusivement pour lui les temps
et venu il soit disant il y avait un 33
tours où il y avait un film donc il y
avait des chansons et avec un petit
studio d'enregistrement qui faisait ces
gens de disques clandestins qu'on a
appelée qu'on appelle toujours les
maquettes les disques des démonstrations
c'est à dire après avoir écrit la
chanson on est allé avec quatre cinq
musiciens on a fait un petit discours
titre maquette qui a jamais jamais vu la
lumière du jour sauf pour elvis ou pour
l'éditeur pour la maison disent que vous
l'avez rencontré une liste non non
jamais je vais parler ni au téléphone et
n'a jamais écrit une carte postale rien
du tout mais il n'était pas abordable il
était barricadé dans un hôtel ou ou un
non non c'est à dire qu'il y en avait
quelques-uns quelques privilégiés mon
éditeur quelques jours de la compagnie
de disques quelques compositeurs et
paroliers aussi mais moi je ne sais pas
pourquoi par un hasard de la vie et je
n'ai jamais rencontré et qui hélas
d'après vous quelle influence a eu elvis
presley sur la musique en général la
musique moderne
ben c'est à dire pour moi je crois que
en ce qui concerne le rock'n roll il n'y
avait vraiment que lui je ne veux pas
dire qu'il n'y avait pas d'autres mais
c'est sûr et certain au sommet loin au
delà de tout le monde il y avait qu elle
vise presley je crois que tout le monde
tous les artistes de sa génération de
son époque
vous voulez bien copier le style ou au
moins reconnaissez leur dette envers
elle vit c'est sûr et certain que
c'était quand même
celui-là qui est t on avant de tout et
en tant qu'américains et vous influencer
vous étiez jeune vous avez 17 ans je
pense à l'époque ma 10 à 18 ans non oui
papa il a commencé oui c'est à dire que
pour moi c'était c'était autre chose
moi j'étais pas tellement influencée
puisque j'ai travaillé là dedans mais
c'est sûr et certain qu'ils son
influence était partout incroyable merci
morte dans la sphère kappler la police
allemande a annoncé ce matin qu'elle
arrêtait les recherches en vue de
retrouver le criminel de guerre nazi
en fait c'est une véritable clause de
style car la justice allemande
elle a annoncé cet après midi
officiellement car baird kappler se
trouvait en basse saxe
entre temps on a même appris qu'après
l'épisode de la malle l'hôpital il
s'était déguisé en curé pour franchir la
frontière avant de prendre un avion
privé piloté par des complices qui l'ont
donc aider à trouver le refuge dans le
village de zaho
en allemagne la sphère kappler qui
provoque un tollé en italie en
particulier alors qu'en allemagne
fédérale l'opinion publique et certains
journaux semblent accepter avec disons
complaisance l'évasion de l'ancien
colonel et 16 ans après tellement de les
éditorialistes que s'attache surtout à
constater le report de la rencontre
andreotti helmut schmidt d'une façon
générale on ne considèrent cependant pas
que les relations entre gouvernements
bonne rome seront compromises gravement
il en est tout autrement des relations
entre allemands et italiens en général
les allemands constate en effet un
journal de fait ce matin que l'italie
pays d'origine du fascisme conjure un
peu facilement son passé en le balayant
devant la porte de l'allemagne plutôt
que devant la sienne ce ne sont pas là
des propos qui arrangeront les choses
entre rome et bonne depuis plusieurs
mois en effet d'après allemand de décret
une italie du désordre et de la
corruption
alors que des journalistes italiens ont
réponse redécouvre une allemagne qu'il
considère redevenu arrogante et
matérialiste il reste que 32 ans après
la guerre les allemands attendent de
leurs voisins qu'il commence à oublier
les atrocités du nazisme eux-mêmes
adoptent de plus en plus des attitudes
plus permissive par rapport à des
groupuscules nazis qui s'agite beaucoup
sur la scène intérieure allemande mais
qui n'ont pratiquement aucune
signification politique
j insiste
ces vieillards au garde à vous devant un
monument aux morts son ancien ss de la
campagne russe ostensiblement et avec
300 autres membres des waffen ss
ils entendent honorer la mémoire
d'autres et c'est tombé au front et
larmes versées sur un parent ou un nazi
anonyme ne tiennent pas compte des
centaines de milliers de civils exécutés
par ses divisions délices du troisième
reich
[Musique]
sous une forte protection policière
quelque 150 réunions de ce genre ont eu
lieu en allemagne depuis deux ans la
vieille camaraderie nazis qui bénéficie
de soutiens dans l'injustice l'industrie
et la politique a pignon sur rue en
dépit des quelques protestations que ces
manifestations suscite
incroyable mais vrai face à des
contre-manifestants sidéré c'est ancien
ss aux en pleine rue justifier le
massacre d'oradour un massacre qu'il
répéterait il le fallait
de telles créatures existe toujours
leurs propos soulèvent l'écoeurement des
vins allemands
politiquement c'est à corrigibles ne
représentent cependant plus rien en
allemagne fédérale où 60% des habitants
actuels n'ont pas vécu confirmant le
nazisme c'est une fille protestent
contre ces rassemblements pour elle trop
de crimes ont été commis
informé des atrocités du passé par son
père ce garçon s'indigne que c'est
ancien ss est encore la fierté et la
décence de se rassembler d'une manière
générale il faut cependant dire que les
allemands manifestent de plus en plus de
complaisance envers les anciennes
agissent ils ne veulent pas tous comme
c'est interlocuteur assumer l'histoire
même celle de l'époque de ses parents
cet homme tient à démontrer par son
opposition que les jeunes de son pays se
sont éloignés les erreurs du passé et
qu'ils veulent qu'elles ne se répètent
plus il reste que même sa paire est
fréquente
ces protestations n'ont pas encore gêné
les anciens combattants du nazisme
retour en france avec le feuilleton
politique du mois de juillet du mois
d'août à savoir la polémique entre le
parti communiste et le parti socialiste
chaque matin les observateurs et les de
la chose politique se précipitent qui
sur un hebdomadaire qui sur un quotidien
qui sur une émission de radio pour
savoir où on est la querelle qui attaque
qui répond et surtout sur quel ton après
françois mitterrand répondant aux
communistes henri alleg voici ce matin
dans l'humanité france est là
art qui répond elle même à mitterrand et
puis ce soir
réponse de la réponse lionel jospin du
parti socialiste renvoie la balle dans
une interview accordée au monde
et apparemment gens face à jean françois
kahn il renvoie la balle assez loin oui
il ya même deux deux éléments nouveaux
il y a cet article jospin extrêmement
musclée dans le monde
et puis déjà un article de marché qui va
paraître demain dans l'humanité qui est
également assez rech
je crois que l'article de jospin marque
une étape dans ce dans cette polémique
où se débat comme disait communiste
car enfin pour les gens qui suivent ce
débat d'une façon un peu lointaine ou
bien les gens qui étaient en vacances
par exemple etc ont suivi ça comme ça
depuis la plage ça paraît un peu bizarre
un peu surréaliste un peu irréel parce
que c'est un débat à une personne
il y a le parti communiste qui dit voilà
il ya des divergences entre nous elles
sont très graves
il faut en parler il faut le mettre sur
la place publique alors on fonce vers
les socialistes on leur demande qu'un ya
des divergences très grave qu'est ce que
vous en pensez aux n'exagérons rien
distille c'est monsieur marché quelle
mauvaise humeur c'est pas si grave que
ça vous sur le détail tout va très bien
alors on va vers les commissions dues au
fait des socialistes que ça va très bien
pas du tout dit des communistes ça va
très très mal
bon il ya un côté un peu jusqu'à présent
surréel l'élément nouveau c'est
qu'aujourd'hui dans le monde
lionel jospin qui est un des lieutenants
de mitterrand reprend la balle au bond
et répond point par point à la aux
attaques argumentation aux
argumentations communiste alors si vous
voulez maintenant on peut si vous voulez
reconstituer un peu le débat par exemple
les communistes 10 aux socialistes vous
refuser le débat démocratique voulait
pas qu'on parle de divergence devant le
peuple
aqua lionel jospin c'est mitterand qui
derrière dit comment vous nous faites
des leçons de démocratie
enfin la façon dont sans consulter vos
adhérents vous avez changé de politique
sur la force de frappe ou sur l'
élection du parlement européen au
suffrage universel
c'est pas très démocratique non plus
donc vous voyez
il fait un si bref procès sur le plan
des mots démocratie autre chose le les
communistes disent aussi les questions
que nous posons c'est des questions que
nous posons nom du peuple et la classe
ouvrière à quoi les communes et
socialistes dans la voix lionel jospin
réponde enfin au nom de quoi vous n'êtes
pas le peuple français vous n'avez que
20%
vous êtes minoritaires dans l'union de
la gauche vous n'êtes la classe ouvrière
ne vous appartient pas et vous avez fait
assez d'erreurs dans le passé pour être
prudents aujourd'hui et troisième point
et c'est peut-être le plus important
vous savez que les communistes laisse
entendre que les socialistes pourraient
tenter par l'atlantisme c'est à dire
alors l'alliance avec les américains
alors la jospin réponse d'accord nous
avons été pro américain nous avons fait
des progrès nous sommes beaucoup plus
indépendants maintenant mais vous êtes
vous vraiment indépendant vis-à-vis des
mines soviétiques et il dit c'est
curieux depuis quelques temps je lis
dans l'humanité des articles contre les
gouvernements socialistes
mais je ne nie pas grand chose sur la
violation des droits de l'homme dans les
pays de l'est et vous voyez donc que le
ton monte singulièrement et donc à une
dialectique des attitudes et une
dialectique des mots merci jean françois
kahn de leur côté les partis politiques
de la majorité ont tenu aujourd'hui une
cinquième réunion il s'agit toujours de
répartir les circonscriptions entre
leurs candidats la question du manifeste
ne sera abordée que le 24 août prochain
au conseil des ministres de ce matin à
l'elysée d'abord une précision de
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing il n'y
aura pas de décisions spectaculaires
prochainement cela pour couper court à
de nouvelles rumeurs d'élections
anticipées les décisions essentielles de
ce conseil d'abord la nomination de
monsieur paul camou ce préfet de région
il devient contrôleur des sociétés
sidérurgiques il va veiller disons au
respect des engagements financiers
souscrits par ces entreprises
et puis aussi au respect des objectifs
industriels et sociaux
il a tout pouvoir d'investigation sur
pièces et sur place
réaction de la cgt négative le
gouvernement qui finance le
démantèlement de la serrure j de la
sidérurgie pardon va en même temps
veiller à sa pleine application dit la
cgt au conseil des ministres aussi un
million d'anciens combattants ont été
mis sur un pied d'égalité ce de 14-18 et
ceux des conflits ultérieurs toucheront
maintenant 800 francs par an environ
pour sa part monsieur monory le ministre
de l'industrie a expliqué la politique
d'approvisionnement de là
sans matières premières minérales il a
dressé un premier bilan des ressources
minières en france proposer des mesures
d'incitation pour les prospections et
suivant les consignes du chef de l'état
les janvier 75 il a étudié les mesures
qui peuvent diminuer le degré de
dépendance de la france
les matières premières c'est vraiment le
talon d'achille de notre économie car la
france doit non seulement payer la
facture pétrole 55 milliards de francs
par an mais aussi la facture café 7
milliards la facture cuivre la facture
phosphates et bien d'autres
la france a dû faire du soufre de la
bauxite de la potasse et même du nickel
grâce à la nouvelle calédonie mais pour
le reste pour le cuivre le phosphate
l'antimoine le chrome l'argent nous
dépendons quasiment complètement de
l'étranger considérons le cuivre par
exemple près de 40% de nos
approvisionnements bay viennent
d'afrique
si le zaïre où la zambie connu une crise
intérieure ou des soubresauts politiques
ce sont nos usines qui en subissent les
conséquences
cette dépendance de la france se traduit
d'abord par une note lourde à payer est
presque du jour en dollars son montant
varie selon les fluctuations des cours
mondiaux de ces produits selon que les
prix flambent ou chute l'an passé en 76
la note était le 10 milliards de francs
c'est pour pouvoir non seulement
garantir nos approvisionnements mais
aussi pour pouvoir acheter au meilleur
prix
il faut diversifier nos sources
il n'est pas bon que 80% du phosphate
dont a besoin notre industrie des
engrais soit importé d'afrique du maroc
pour la moitié ces matières premières
heureusement nous coûte quand même moins
cher que le pétrole mais elles sont
d'une autre façon tout aussi stratégique
sans chrome plus à sin oxydable sans
argent métal + 2 brasure sur les trains
avant d r 16 renault pour assurer notre
sécurité d'approvisionnement au moindre
prix la politique des pouvoirs publics
souriante dans plusieurs directions
d'abord la recherche c'est-à-dire
l'inventaire des ressources minières
encore disponible en france et on a fait
récemment des découvertes intéressantes
en bretagne dans le sud du massif
central et dans les pyrénées le
recyclage qui permet le réemploi de
métaux ayant déjà serré la récupération
qu'il faut organiser la constitution de
stocks quand les prix sont bas depuis
deux ans la france a par exemple acheté
pour les stocker pour 250 millions de
francs de métaux non ferreux et par
dessus tout un maître mot économie
épargne fabriquer autant avec moins de
matières premières
c'est non seulement produire moins cher
c'était aussi produire plus sûres
toujours au conseil des ministres de ce
matin monsieur meillerie le ministre de
l'agriculture s'est expliqué sur le
déroulement des campagnes agricoles en
valéry giscard d'estaing qui se rend
demain dans la meuse étudiera sur place
un certain nombre de problèmes agricoles
pour commencer demain matin le chef de
l'état visitera une usine d'aliments de
bétail
un secteur que les agriculteurs de l'est
voudrait bien voir se développer
davantage
reportage de jean louis le sel
sur les scènes qui est allé visiter
aujourd'hui cette conscience
traditionnellement la meuse est un
département où l'élevage est
prépondérant notamment l'industrie
laitière
or qui dit lei ipte il est ce qu'on
appelle en termes techniques
le sérum jadis on utilisait ce sérum
pour élever les ports le reste on s'en
débarrasser comme on pouvait
généralement ans le délai ressent dans
les rivières aujourd'hui il n'y a
presque plus de ports et les mesures
antipollution sont devenues draconiennes
pour subsister
les entreprises de la région ont dû se
regrouper et rouvert en commun des
débouchés pour le team et pour fêter ces
roms et pour des dimensions de ses rails
au moins 58 ans bits par an il n'est pas
pensable d'investir plusieurs millions
de nouveaux francs dans les unités comme
ici pour pouvoir nous mêmes frais
téléphone ces roms comme le thème à
découvrir donc je crois je suis certain
que bas les cours pour les petites et
moyennes entreprises telles que les
normes ils ont permis de survivre bas
les cours dans la banlieue de verdun
c'est là où se trouve l'usiné qui est né
de cette constatation des industriels du
lait lusine sous valéry giscard
d'estaing visitera demain matin
cinquante cinq laiteries et fromageries
de l'est de la france viennent d'y
vendre leur sérum du sérum qui séchait
par étapes successives donnera dans la
plupart des cartes du lactose entoure
jusqu'à présent ce produit était surtout
destiné à enrichir les aliments pour le
bétail
mais depuis quelques temps aussi
surprenant que cela puisse paraître
lusine de balai cours oriente sa
production vers l'alimentation humaine
une part importante de notre production
consiste en une déminéralisation du
sérum c'est à dire que nous retirons du
sérum
issus du lait de vache un certain nombre
de constituants des sels minéraux
essentiellement de façon à rapprocher sa
composition de
celle du lait maternel mais qu'est ce
qu'il ya en fait d'exceptionnel dans
cette usine est ce que cette usine
d'exceptionnel c'est je crois et
la plus importante usine de france dans
sa branche
je vous parlais tout à l'heure des
sérums déminéralisée c'est la deuxième
installation mondial de déminéralisation
de sérum et c'est on peut dire que c'est
une très grosse unité de dépollution
puisque nous traitons chaque année
environ 500 millions de litres de ces
roms
autant de produits qui n'est pas rejetée
dans les rivières de l'est de la france
bien sûr au cours de ce voyage éclair en
meuse le chef de l'état ne se contentera
pas de visiter les usines de balai cours
il se rendra également dans une
coopérative agricole de la région et
s'entretiendra avec plusieurs élus
locaux
là on peut penser que la politique
reprendra ses droits
d'autant plus que depuis quelques années
chaque consultation électorale en meuse
donne à la gauche
l'occasion de grignoter des positions
traditionnellement tenue par la majorité
la sphère du double meurtre près de
saint tropez
walter folie l'italien inculpé
d'assassinât a été mis hors de cause
aujourd'hui par l'intervention d'un
témoin qui lui a fourni un alibi il
pourrait donc être très prochainement
remis en liberté en football il y avait
hier soir la 3e journée du championnat
de france déception pour bastia battu 3
0 par nancy
déception pour lens aussi battu 2 à 0
par lyon bien sans plus pour
saint-etienne 0 à 0 à reims paris saint
germain 1 à strasbourg
par contre coup de chapeau réel coup de
chapeau à monaco qui gagne par 4 0
monaco et lyon sont en tête du
championnat et voici le premier but qui
va être réussie dans quelques instants
par christian d'alger d'un tir dans la
lucarne il a ouvert ainsi la marque sur
coup franc
c'est le plus logiquement du monde donc
monaco enlevé son troisième succès
consécutif
sept minutes plus tard moisan transfuge
d'angoulême partait à l'ailé droite
centré sur d'alger encore lui et après
un une deux avec ronis inscrivait le
deuxième but 2 0
ce n'était pas fini car la machine
bordelaise se voyait littéralement
désorganisé d'alger encore lui allait
crucifier littéralement les girondins à
la suite d'un nouveau une deux avec
noguès cette fois 3 0
l'addition était lourde augmenté d'un
nouveau but à la dernière minute par
moisan moisan d'alger deux grands hommes
du match qui s'est déroulé sous les yeux
du sélectionneur michel hidalgo qui a
retenu déjà d'alger pour france hambourg
pour parc des princes la semaine
prochaine belle victoire également de
lyon face à lens en jaune après une
première mi temps médiocre
le premier but est inscrit ici par
lacombe qui a trompé tempe et peu de
temps après le début de la seconde
période sur une passe de gare la
rencontre a alors pris une très belle
allure
lyon manquait de cohésion mais
bénéficier de contres favorables et là
qu'on vous allez le voir allait
récidiver à la 76e minute après quelques
attaques des lensois c'est un succès qui
confirme pour l'ol son bon début de
championnat tandis que lens semble
peiner pour trouver son rythme à l'image
d'une ligne d'attaqué bien peu efficace
et voici ce deuxième but score final
donc 2 à 0
magnifique météo un peu moins magnifique
pour demain jeudi le temps sera orageux
de la méditerranée aux alpes et du
nord-est au nord avec des orages encore
au cours de la journée des plus
intermittentes
près de la manche sur le reste de la
france le temps sera plus frais très
nuageux et brumeux
puis il deviendra variable avec des
averses et éclaircies deviendront belle
sur le languedoc
je rappelle que vous avez deux
rendez-vous dans la soirée avec
l'actualité sur antenne 2 à 21h45 un
magazine sur les énergies nouvelles et
énergie solaire en particulier c'est
question de temps le magazine présenté
par louis blériot et georges leclercq et
puis le dernier journal présenté tout à
fait en fin de soirée par bernard rapp
je vous souhaite une très belle soirée
[Musique]